this video is astonishing crazy so  swimming  near the hamptons there off of long  island in new york it's a little bit  tenuous because of this there's a frenzy  of sharks that are kind of swimming  around there and scurrying up all the  fish  wow this drone video that we're showing  you right now it  shows sharks you can see them swimming  and feeding on massive schools of bait  and bunker fish this week several towns  have shut down  all of their beaches no people have been  attacked by the sharks  but officials say it's simply an  abundance of caution  official life local lifeguards excuse me  i've set up shark patrol teams  in places where swimming is still  allowed but  you can see how nerve-wracking it would  be to be out in the water and know that  they're out there  swimming around eating i mean i'm glad  i'm not a fish  here's